there is no relationship quite like the  friendship between Canada in the United  States the deep ties of economics of  business of friends of culture of people  traveling back and forth Canada and  America unites that's Justin Trudeau and  Ivanka Trump happily sitting together  enjoying the play about Canadians  helping Americans the PM flew in from  Ottawa to meet the whole cast of the  homegrown hit come from away Ivanka  skipped her dad's rally in Nashville to  jet in from DC as Justin special guest  she watched from the stalls as he opened  the performance the food Ivanka was  taking in the true story which promotes  cultural understanding and includes  subplots condemning Muslim intolerance  all while her father battles for his  travel ban on Muslims and refugees the  fact is we have a friendship between our  two countries that are like no other and  this really emphasizes it seeing so many  good friends gathered here today